una imagen que da la vuelta al mundo es
la de un expresidente entregándose a la
policía que rodeaba su casa un juez
hondureño había ordenado la detención
provisional de juan orlando hernández
tras la petición de extradición
presentada por eeuu esto sólo dos
semanas después de que dejara el poder y
estos son los señalamientos en su contra
[Música]
se acusa el expresidente de omitir sus
funciones desde 2014 habría conspirado
para recibir toneladas de cocaína desde
colombia y venezuela y habría permitido
que la policía y el ejército las
protegerán para que llegaran a estados
unidos mientras se permitían actos de
violencia brutales a cambio juan orlando
hernández habría recibido millones de
dólares del narcotráfico la defensora de
derechos humanos reina rivera dijo a
france 24 que estas prácticas eran un
secreto a voces y obviamente ha tenido
un impacto muy fuerte en la población
hondureña pero también evidenciando en
la debilidad de las instituciones
públicas que en los últimos años no han
sido capaces de procesar o investigar
este tipo de señalamientos
en marzo de 2021 su hermano tony
hernández fue sentenciado a cadena
perpetua y el mismo año 12 senadores
estadounidenses habían apoyado un
proyecto para aislar al ex presidente
entre ellos patrick leigh que denunció
la pasividad de las administraciones a
lo largo de los últimos ocho años
de aprobación e impunidad las sucesivas
administraciones estadounidenses
mancillaron nuestra reputación al tratar
a hernández como un amigo y socio juan
orlando siempre negó los lazos con el
narcotráfico al que asegura que combatió
sin embargo todo apunta a que en un
plazo de tres meses será extraditado a
eeuu